all right matt hardy uh without a doubt
one half of i'd say the most famous
the most respected brotherhood in pro
wrestling
but i want to put you on the hot seat a
little bit today i did something similar
with christian cage a couple weeks back
i would like to get your mount rushmore
of pro wrestling brothers
fictional or real i'll leave that up to
you okay
fictional or real uh that makes it a
little more tricky
um i to be a little egotistical about
myself and my brother on it
uh i'll put edge and christian on as
well i'll put the dudley's on it
and i can't go without putting the road
wars even though they technically
weren't brothers they were brothers in
paint so
i i got to put them the road wars legion
of doom are definitely going to always
go down is most likely the greatest tag
team in history
agreed wholeheartedly on my end and no
disres you know no shame in putting
yourselves on there i think it's well
deserved i'm really happy that we're
doing this interview now because we're
about a couple weeks removed now to if
i'm not mistaken the
second biggest nielsen rating for an
episode of aew dynamite ever
headlined by yours truly matt hardy
opposite darby allen
can you tell me what it felt like to see
that number and to see that not only did
you at this stage of your career get to
put in
a nearly a record-breaking number but to
get to do it opposite a future star in
this industry in darby allen
i mean it was super exciting it was our
first week unopposed
so i was very happy to be in that slot
and darby is is starting to
to prove to be a ratings guy because
people really like him and there is
he gets it so much he reminds me on
brother in so many ways
as how he sells from underneath he gets
sympathy and he's just he's cool
the kids like him he's super cool and me
at this stage of the game being an older
competitor
especially with the younger aw audience
i am the perfect
bad guy i think for a darby allen or
someone like that
so i was expecting them to be big i hope
we would break a million
and do a good number but when we heard
1.219 i was like blown away and super
happy
super excited and i really think it was
a good payoff because
people didn't know when they tuned in if
darby allen was going to
lose the tnt title or retain the tnt
title and i think that was part of the
charm
just this past weekend kenny omega aew
world champion also claimed the impact
wrestling belts year old stomping ground
when you and jeff hardy were on your way
up it was you know the territory days
were kind of ending
it was in the thick of the attitude era
what's it like for you now in this stage
to sort of be experiencing this
renaissance
of all these different organizations
from all over the world sort of joining
forces and working together
i i think it's great i've always thought
it was great for business you know
a lot of people don't know about this
it's not a well-known fact but i had
been
negotiating and working with the young
bucks and
right before my brother and i left
impact to return to wwe
we were actually going to do a ring of
honor impact crossover angle with the
hardys
with the hardys and the young bucks for
three or four months and we had that set
but then
some things changed in their management
and then it ended up we returned to wwe
once we ended up leaving
so i'm all down for it i've always been
down from it from the beginning and i
think
especially considering wwe is such a
a massive global promotion i think any
other promotion that is up and coming
when they work with other promotion it
had it helps to add the
element of unpredictability and
unpredictability is what makes wrestling
success
in 2021 i think more than anything else
because information is out there so many
people see spoilers so many people
have a clue of what's going on because
the internet is is very
wide and people know so i think the more
you can surprise people you have someone
show up on this promotion or
someone show up on aaw or someone show
up in new japan i think it really adds
that unpredictability to pro wrestling
you i think rightfully so are credited
with this
revolutionizing of these cinematic
wrestling matches and for those who may
not be quite on the up and up these are
not generally matches that take place
live in a pro wrestling ring but they're
more kind of movie style matches
in different settings i was thinking
about and i think one of the best
things that's come out of this is not
just the swath of creative angles but
these cinematic matches have given
legendary wrestlers like
sting and the undertaker a chance to go
out on their own terms where
you know the live setting might be a
little too taxing on their bodies
have you thought of that at all that you
know you've helped spearhead something
that is now giving these guys a chance
to go out in a meaningful way
yes i have i mean my initial mindset
in doing broken matt hardy in the very
beginning
uh was to look for longevity because i
knew what the new kids were doing and as
the style was changing in
2000 you know 2015 2016 2017 i'm like
well i'm not 25 anymore
you know so what if i did something
different a throwback to the old days of
undertaker and papashango
something a little magical and and then
maybe we do matches that are
shot more like a movie you know more
like a piece of cinema
and then that could conserve my body and
i could also do a lot more cool stuff
in the realm of the character so that
was my whole mindset behind doing that
and really i want to get my brother
doing it because my brother has
such an addiction to doing swanton's and
whispering the winds and
he wants to do everything because he's
so passionate and he feels like he his
fans deserve it
that he wants to give everything i was
like dude you're getting older they want
to see jeff hardy your star you can't
beat up your body every single night so
that was my
original mindset for even starting the
whole cinematic thing in
in the broken universe but considering
it gave taker a great match against aj
styles that was amazing i love the
boneyard match
and sting now being aw and being able to
do these cinematic matches where he can
be
the sting of old you it feels really
special and you never know what you're
going to get i think that's amazing so
if i did help contribute to the uh
the new end of cinematic matches i am
i'm very proud of that fact
do you have two favorites of all these
cinema cinematic matches your own and
then
one that you did not take part in
yeah i i mean it's tough like the final
deletion
will always be famous because it was
like the first major one
i knew when we did the first contract
signing with broken matt hardy and
my brother jeff hardy people were it was
so polarizing and people were so split
over it but i knew we had something
because so many people were locked in
and then the final deletion like it went
viral you know over
the course of a couple days and that's
like a big deal looking back
structurally it wasn't as good as some
of the other things i was in
probably my favorite match that i've
ever done cinematically was the
apocalypto tag team match from total
non-stop deletion
uh one of my favorite matches i think
that i've watched was the undertaker aj
styles thing because i know undertaker
really wanted
to go out on a good note and he had a
couple matches where he was in the ring
live and i know it didn't live up to his
expectations and he was let down by them
so i'm so happy you got to go out on
that high note with aj styles
speaking of your brother uh you guys
have both mentioned that you would like
to end your careers as a tag team the
same way you began i was wondering at
this stage was it what is it like being
on an ascent
counter programming is it create any
sort of competitive spark at all to see
what your brother is doing and his
promotion for him to see what you're
doing in yours
no i mean we always text each other
before the shows and we go hey man are
you on the night or when you on or what
are you doing
we just kind of keep up with it i don't
think there's any competition
any longer i think we're just both
supportive of one another
so so it's cool we've almost done it
enough where there was a point where i
was at wwe and he was a tna
and he was a tna and i was at roh i mean
we've kind of done this before so
it's uh it's kind of old hat in some
ways but we're now more than ever just
supportive of one another
that's great to hear as we start to wrap
up you have you know we're entertainment
tonight canada and
your career does not end with pro
wrestling do you have any fond memories
of
that 70s show where i'd like to add you
have a victory over your brother
i do yeah i i enjoyed that 70s show we
were very young
uh new guys we hadn't been put with
michael hayes we hadn't changed into the
new hardy boys
with the kick wear pants at that time so
just to get on that show and get the
opportunity to
you know perform in an acting role was
so cool
and we were so flattered to be chosen
for it and it was so much fun it was
an amazing learning experience in so so
many ways
growing up i was a huge fan of fear
factor and
you can imagine i was figuratively
eating it up when i saw you and your
brother and the
other wrestlers on there you literally
had to eat some nasty nasty
is that a show that you would ever do
again should the opportunity emerge
i would i would do for vector again i
had a blast doing it and
uh i i i was worried like maybe they
might do something with the physical
challenges that might be too much for me
that i couldn't do
but when it came to like eating or doing
something gross or being afraid i wasn't
worried about that at all
i'm i'm good with all that stuff perfect
well matt uh we'll leave it there
so thank you so much for doing this
today it's a big honor